whereas to fill in the blanks to
complete the equation so they have
eighty six point nine three is equal to
five tens plus blank ones plus three
plus nine tenths plus three hundredths
so let me expand out eighty six point
nine three and just think about how I
could regroup the value in the different
places so that I get something more
close or exactly what we have on the
right hand side so the eight and eighty
six point nine three that's in the tens
place so it literally represents eight
tens so I can write that down as eighty
so let me do that this eighty the six in
eighty six represents six one so I can
write that down as six then the nine in
eighty six point nine three that's nine
tenths so I could write that down I
could write this nine that's right -
that's right of the decimal place this
is plus nine tenths and then the three
in eighty six point nine three that is
in the hundredths place it represents
three hundredths so this is plus three
over a hundred so I've expanded out what
I thumbr that I have on the left now let
me write out what they have on the right
again so this is going to be equal to
they have five tens here so I'll write
all the tens places in this red color
then they have blank ones so I'm going
to do that I'm just going to literally
write out a blank plus blank plus nine
tenths so the nine tenths is still nine
tenths plus three hundredths plus three
hundred so let me make sure that we
color code this so that's the nine
tenths this is the five tens that's the
fifty we have the blank ones that's this
right over here nine tenths and then
finally we have the three hundredths
three hundred so plus three over a
hundred so how do we get the right-hand
side to be the exact same thing as the
left-hand side and by adjusting this
blank well both sides have a three
hundred saan it both sides have a nine
tenths on it and so what's really
different about the two sides is on the
left hand side
this color that we can actually see on
the left hand side you have an 80 plus a
6 on the right hand side you have a 50
plus a blank so 80 plus 6 is clearly 86
so what does 50 have to be or it has to
be added to 50 to get to 86 well you
have to add 36 you have to add 36 so now
both sides add up to the same thing
80 plus 6 is 86 50 plus 36 is 86 then
you have 9/10 9/10 3/100 3/100 now you
might be saying hey wait you know you've
ordered 36 here does this literally mean
36 ones and I will say yes it literally
represents 36 ones you could literally
view this this is the same thing as 36
times 1 so we can rewrite this as or we
can fill in the blank here eighty six
point nine three is equal to five tens
plus 36 ones plus nine tenths plus three
hundredths and I encourage you to add
this up you will get eighty six point
nine three now what have we essentially
done here well what we essentially did
if you compare the 8 and the 5 right
over here you see that we took three
from the tens place we took three from
the tens place but taking three from the
tens place is essentially taking 30 is
taking 30 from that from that value that
it represents so we took 30 from the
tens place and we gave that 30 to the
ones place we gave that 30 to the ones
place so you had 86 you take 30 away you
have 50 in the tens place represented by
this 5 and then you give that 30 to the
ones place you have 36 you have 36 ones